i'm out to find another disgruntled vet
i'll have detailed instructions but make
sure you protect the lombardi trophies
worse you know me get me started earlier
i'll throw a little fit let's party
uh the only person supporting us is yg
again we had a 3d fire zone brought the
niggle off the edge and the safety
dropped down you know word i'ma use that
in man
that must be whitworth with the bree
since he here to win the natty holy [ __ ]
the cool kids hey yo come through
[Music]
was anyone expecting the bengals oh i
heard they bring the house down
it's getting pretty late
cool we're gonna keep going we just
won't let them go off
yo my bad bookshelf was talking
it's the j o single e
sup lebron yo burro m i've never been to
a party with two chill white dudes
oh i've been alright to die since week
10. i'm beginning to feel like i'm a gat
guy that guy i'm leonardo dicaprio and i
do not care what sport this is all right
hear me out you replace brody
[Applause]
i got zack stacks y'all please be
careful please i did not leave detroit
for this remember detroit never leaves
you yes mr mathers
man i wish gridiron heights taught me
about saving money we got surprisingly
great rates at state farm this show is
perfect
[Music]
so i don't even use protection all right
enough three and out you go sorry guy i
kind of just do whatever the [ __ ] got
goddamn please that worry on your face
that's mcfear son
let's go guide from bagels defense
do not test me i will go down in flames
this is our house well we share it but
still are we all in yes [ __ ] them pics
hey look my keys still work
damn you got good at the silent count
not much of a chase man you just trash
stop all this football drama in this
dancery
looks like some sort of football fight
broke out in a well-produced hip-hop
dancery no matter what happens hell of a
party
are you joking i don't do that anymore
[Music]
is that
zack how the hell did you get here what
huh just a little zack nap so what i let
lucid had fun you're not my dad anymore
zach you're two years older than me
you